pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien les mains du duo yodé sa nation à
colombes entre la france et l'irlande
festival offensif des français et des
irlandais en bas noirs qui emporte
l'adhésion des 60000 spectateurs
c'est pourtant par les coups de pied que
la france map sa supériorité au début du
match la france frappent trois points
sur un drop albaladejo le demi
d'ouverture suivi d'un autre droit près
aussi exactement dans les mêmes
conditions sont sentis mulet et voilà et
je l'en de nullement découragé attaque à
outrance hewitt de trois-quarts centre
mais trois adversaires dans le vent des
marques sont déliées profite il n'a
aucune peine à déborder michel vannier
d'attac irlandaise et à leurs supérieurs
à l'attack français
ce sont les avants de l'équipe de france
les bulldozers soutenus par leur demi
qui force le destin
le résultat ne se fait pas attendre et
c'est un essai pour ces lahya
un autre essai que va marquer amédée
domenech sur un extraordinaire départ du
demi de mêlée lacroix rien ne peut
arrêter domenech ne fait rien ne peut
arrêter les avants français
domenech encore numéro deux relances
l'attaquent pour ces trois quarts
rancoule déborde et marque en coin
entre temps elle va l'a déjoué à placer
un drop entre les deux poteaux 18 à 3
pour la france le score est très sévère
pour les irlandais qui ne baisse jamais
les bras et qui attaque de leur côté
sous tous les ans
[Musique]
brophy numéro encore lui échappe à tout
le monde et marque le plus bel essai du
match après une course de 70 mètres ce
match france irlande et la plus belle
rencontre de rugby de la saison entre
les deux meilleures équipes du tournoi
des six nations
encore un essai pour la france
transformé par bouquets 23,6 et tout de
même trop dur pour les irlandais
oui
confiée à perdre canaveral à une fusée
torero voici le nouveau satellite
artificiel américain tyrosse un surnommé
à cause de sa forme
carton à chapeau en fait il renferme
deux caméras de télévision miniature est
un appareil d'enregistrement magnétique
destiné à stocker les images
rien de très différent quant au
lancement semblable à tous les autres
noms sont
mais une fois placé sur son orbite est
débarrassé du troisième étage
tyrosse qui tourne lui même à 120 tours
minute et capable de ralentir sa propre
vitesse de rotation pour permettre aux
caméras d'entrer en action et de prendre
à quelques 700 km de distance
une série de clichés de 1300 kilomètres
carrés chacun les images sont ensuite
transmises par radio aux stations
américaines moyennant quoi les savants
espère être mieux renseigner sur les
formations des nuages et faire enfin de
la météorologie
une science exacte
[Musique]
au général de gaulle pour le dernier
jour de sa visite une visite qui
réveillait des souvenirs vieux de 20 ans
l'angleterre avait réservé d honneur
exceptionnel ainsi à westminster hall le
général de gaulle devait-il prendre la
parole devant les deux chambres réunies
[Applaudissements]
quel peuple
mieux que la grande bretagne et la
france savent que rien ne s'ouvre à le
mordre
sinon
ce dont elles sont l'une et l'autre par
excellence capable
la sagesse et la fermeté
mais la grande bretagne devait faire à
son hôte une faveur plus exceptionnelle
encore accueilli par le duc de
gloucester le président de la république
devait passer en revue les six régiment
de gardes de la reine honneur qui
jusqu'ici n'avait jamais été concédée à
aucun chef d'état étranger
[Musique]
et
vous
il faut commencer par lisbonne un tour
d'horizon portugais considérer cette
tâche que fait la ville le long de sa
rade naturelle sur laquelle s'ouvre
accueil royal la place du commerce
[Musique]
l'un de ses atouts les jo de carreaux de
faïence si commun à lisbonne reproduit
l'aspect de cette même place avant le
tremblement de terre qui détruisit la
ville en 1755 ensevelissant 30000 morts
sous ses murs écroulés
josé premier là on construisit dans son
ordonnance actuelle et ses statues
monumentales on aura toujours le centre
entre la mer qu'ils regardent et la
ville que domine l'ancienne cité le fort
saint georges et le faubourg dalle
femmes alfama c'est à la fois l'histoire
et le pittoresque de lys paul le coin
que le visiteur peut considérer avec le
plus d'amour dédale de ruelles pavois de
linge qui sèche et de fleurs en pot car
le quartier des pauvres est le seul à
avoir des fleurs aux fenêtres là dessus
une grande chaleur humaine de gens qui
vivent avec à la fois le respect et la
simplicité de la vie ruelle où chaque
porte est un éventaire de nourriture
primitive chou brocoli viande de porc et
poissons forme
en effet la base de toute cuisine
populaire
[Musique]
le pain ici garde de son goût comme sa
valeur
il n'est pas indifférent que la
fantaisie boulangère lui donne parfois
la forme humaine qui n'aimerait alfama
avec son grand goût d'hommes vivant avec
le porteur d'eau qui livre à tous les
étages le guitariste aveugle qui traîne
la mélancolie d'un fado le perroquet à
la fenêtre du vieux marin et le kop qui
vit dans sa ruelle une vie d'amour et
d'eau fraîche mais il ya aussi qu'à
l'ombre du palmiers centenaires
on rencontre deux beaux enfants et que
les pieds nus dont parle la légende ont
en général disparu
[Applaudissements]
maintenant lisbonne n'est pas seulement
alfama lisbonne s'enorgueillit à juste
raison de ces quartiers neufs qui
s'élargissent chaque année et qui
peuvent lui assurer le titre de ville
pilote de la construction il lui faut
loger aujourd'hui plus d'un million
d'habitants et les nouvelles avenues de
cette ville sans vent lieu des bush
juste sur les pâtures bâti sur cette
colline dit on comme rome dit-on encore
lisbonne a naturellement des transports
appropriée aux différences de niveaux
funiculaire de toutes sortes et cet
ascenseur de style cathédrale construit
par un certain eiffel qui avant
d'aborder la construction des tours
métalliques fuite ici des débuts
remarqués keller respire ton à lisbonne
l'affluence britannique dont on a tant
parlé n'apparaît vraiment qu'à travers
l' agence cook les autobus à double
étage
l'étape à gary anglaise et le british
bas
l' influence française et plus accuser
des magasins de mode aux librairies
on sent la france combien de lisbonne et
par le français
et le lycée français qui compte
aujourd'hui deux mille élèves en or et
6000 demain s'ils pouvaient triplé ses
classes
l'ère du portugal et ses particularismes
on les découvrira facilement le long
terme une famille angolaise en vacances
qui passe dans l'indifférence générale
un prêtre de race noire un commerçant de
type 1 d'o'malley des visages plus ou
moins bronzé affirme l'absence absolue
de racisme dans l'esprit portugais sur
les trottoirs du rocío qui le coeur de
lisbonne
ces personnages ne font pas tâche aux
exceptions au milieu des visages
strictement portugais dont la veste à
col de fourrure rappelle qu'ils sont les
fils des chasseurs de look
[Musique]
silhouette significative un prêtre en
costume civil l'état et et se veut
laïque un marchand de billets de loterie
ils sont nombreux c'est le produit des
loteries qui assure en grande partie
l'entretien des hôpitaux
un agent en bonne santé sous son faux
casque colonial une varina et son
puissant de fleurs comme pour montrer
que la peine et la fatigue peuvent
s'orner d'un book c'est cela l'espagne
mais il ya autre chose
le port dans lesquels s'étendent sur 13
km et la mer la mer qui est à la fois la
tentation la respiration et la vérité du
portugal
[Musique]